the business secretary has apologized
for his part
the leader of the house has apologized
for his part
but they were following the prime
minister's lead
so will he do the decent thing
and just say sorry for trying to give
the green light to corruption
[Applause]
mr speaker yeah well yes as i've said
before it certainly was a mistake uh to
conflate the case of an into an
individual member no matter how sad with
the point of principle at stake and we
do need we do need a cross-party
approach on an appeals process we also
need mr speaker a cross-party approach
on the way forward and that's why we've
tabled the proposals that we have to
take forward the report of the
independent uh committee for standards
in public life of 2018 uh with those two
key principles uh that everybody in this
house should focus primarily and above
all on their job here in this house and
secondly that no one should exploit
their position in order to advance the
commercial interests of anybody else
that's our position mr speaker we want
to take forward those reforms in the
meantime perhaps he could clear up from
his proposals uh from his proposals
whether he would continue to be able to
take money as he did from mishkon derea
and other legal fans
oh oh oh oh oh oh the other crime prime
minister prime minister as you know and
i do remind you it's prime minister's
questions not leader of the opposition's
questions
kia stammer
that's not an apology
everybody else everybody else has
apologized for him but he won't
apologize for himself a coward not a
leader
weeks
weeks
weeks
weeks defending corruption yesterday a
screeching last-minute u-turn to avoid
defeat on labour's plan to ban mps from
dodgy second contracts but waving one
white flag won't be enough to restore
trust
and there are plenty of opposition days
to come and we will not let the prime
minister water down the proposals or
pretend that it's job done
we still haven't shut the door on the
revolving door where ministers are
regulating a company one minute and
working for them the next there are
plenty of cases that still stain this
house
there are two simple steps to sorting it
out
proper independence and powers for the
business appointments committee and
banning these job swaps
will the prime minister take those steps
hi minister uh mr speaker i've called as
uh you know and indeed you have called
mr speaker for a cross-party approach to
this and what i think we need
what i think we need to do is to work
together on the basis of the
independent report uh by the committee
of standards in public life uh to take
things forward and indeed to address the
appeals process but what i think
everybody can see mr speaker is in a
classic loyally way uh the right
honourable gentleman is now uh trying to
prosecute others for exactly the course
of action that he took himself
and
what i think that what i think the
nation wants to know because his
register is incomplete who paid who paid
mishkan de reyear and who paid the 25
000. who's paying him for research
prime minister i don't want to fall out
about it i've made it very clear it is
prime minister's questions it's not
the opposition to answer your question
but whether we like or not those are the
rules of the game that we're all into
and we play by the rules don't we and we
respect this house so let's respect the
house here
[Music]
mr speaker that newfound commitment to
upholding standards didn't last long
and mr speaker here's the difference
when somebody in my party misbehaves i
kick them out
when somebody
when some or oh
luke
this is not good we lost a dear friend
i want to assure that this house has
learnt from it i don't want each other
to i don't want each other to be shouted
down i want questions to be respected i
expect the public to actually be able to
hear the questions of the answers
because i'm struggling in this chat i
need no more here
mr speaker somebody in my party
misbehaves i kick them out
when somebody in his party misbehaves he
tries to get them off the hook
i lead he covers up
let's try another issue we know that
owen patterson was a paid lobbyist for
randox
we know that he sat in on a call between
randox and the minister responsible for
handling health contracts we know that
randox has been awarded government
contracts worth almost 600 million
pounds
without competition or tender
against that backdrop the public are
concerned that taxpayers money may
have been influenced by paid lobbying
there's only one way to get to the
bottom of this a full transparent
investigation
if he votes for labour's motion this
afternoon
that investigation can start
will he vote for it
or will he vote for another cover-up
i'm very happy to publish all the
details of the randox contract which
have been investigated by the national
audit office already because we're
talking of cover-ups uh i'm sorry mr
speaker uh but we still have not heard
why the honourable general will not tell
them
you talk to the prime minister sit down
prime minister i'm not going to be
challenged you may be the prime minister
of this country but in this house i'm in
charge
end of that
pierced arm
mr speaker i think the prime minister
just said he's happy to publish all the
randox papers in relation to these
contracts so we'll take that
and we'll pursue it and i remind the
prime minister when i was director of
public prosecutions i prosecuted mps who
broke the rule
he has been investigated by every
organization he's ever been elected to
that's the difference
billions of pounds of taxpayers money
handed to their mates and donors
tory mps getting rich by working as
lobbyists one not even bothering to turn
up because he's in the caribbean
advising tax havens
and the prime minister somehow expects
us to believe that he's the man to clean
up westminster
he led his troop through the sewers to
cover up corruption
and he can't even say sorry
the truth is that beneath the bluster he
still thinks it's one rule for him and
another for his mates
at the same time as his governor
engulfed in sleeves they're rowing back
on the promises they made to the north
and it's working people who are paying
the price is it any wonder that people
are beginning to think that the joke
isn't funny anymore
mr speaker mr speaker it is plain uh
from listening to the to the right
honourable gentleman that he seeks to
criticize this government while refusing
uh to explain his own position and
you've ruled on that mr speaker you've
ruled on that mr speaker i hear you i
hear you uh but his own misconduct uh mr
speaker is absolutely
absolutely clear to everybody his own
misconduct is absolutely clear and
meantime mr speaker we will get on on a
cross-party basis we will get on on a
cross-party basis with taking forward
the business that i've outlined and we
will get on with the business of this
government which is leading the country
out of the country
just
i'm sure into here
and if it's correct what i've said
it was about leader of the opposition
misconduct we can't i cannot accuse
someone in miss connor no i may and i
just before the leader of the house
gives me an answer all i'm trying to say
i cannot hear
if it was said i want it withdrawn if he
wasn't i will accept it i'm just just a
moment
prime minister mr speaker i referred to
the right honourable gentleman's
misconduct because that is what he is
guilty of
that is what he is guilty
[Applause]
i don't think this has done this house
any good today
i'll be quite honest i think it's been
i think it's been a little tempered i
think it shows the public
that this house has not learned from the
other week i need this house to gain
respect but it starts by individuals
showing respect to each other